[Music]
megan duchess of sussex now accuses the
royal family of actively encouraging
lies about her
raising tensions to another level ahead
of oprah's interview with her and prince
harry on sunday
now this follows a published claim that
megan mistreated royal staffers which
buckingham palace is investigating
elizabeth palmer has more on the story
from london
this is not only a fight between family
members
it's a battle over brand how do you feel
about the palace hearing you speak
your truth today i don't know how they
could expect
that after all of this time we would
still just be silent
if there is an active role that the firm
is playing
in perpetuating falsehoods about us
megan refers to
the firm that's what britain sometimes
call the royal family
and right now behind the polished smiles
the gloves are
off i i think you could probably only
describe
that relationship now between the two
sides as
all-out war yesterday the london times
reported
allegations that after meghan markle
married prince harry in 2018 and moved
into the royal household
she bullied staff using quote emotional
cruelty and manipulation
and forced two aides to quit but in a
rare move the palace has issued a public
response
we are clearly very concerned about
allegations in the times it said
our hr team will look into the
circumstances
outlined in the article sunday times
royal correspondent roy anika
why would the palace not have just kept
silence i think the feeling is
it it can't be right for
the duke and duchess of sussex to sit
down for two hours with oprah
and say their piece and to not have
people who worked with them and who know
them and who dealt with them
also say their piece megan and harry
have called the allegations
a calculated smear campaign it's also a
new low point in harry's relationship
with the palace
and also the british media something he
discussed with james corden
on the late late show last week we all
know what the british press could be
like
and it was destroying my mental health i
was like this is toxic
yeah so i did what any husband and what
only father would do is like
i need to get my family out of here
now this whole unseemly fight has
erupted at a bad time for the royal
family they're very worried about prince
philip the queen's husband he
uh will be a hundred years old this year
and he's been in hospital we hear this
morning he had
what's being called a minor procedure
for a pre-existing
heart condition but he's going to stay
in hospital at least for a few more days
and at that age
of course it's a worry